he's doing like an inward hand sort
right right in there okay so we're just
starting there but even when I do it if
you watch my hands right forearm out you
don't have to do a strike you're just
gonna you're just gonna put your hand
there
even when I do it do you see how I have
that blend so I'm gonna reach out
towards him and then I was letting it
come back towards me
reach out extension the in space is here
okay and then when we get to the contact
point I am not using my deltoids I've
pulled my scapula down right and I don't
want that deltoids and I'm not I'm now
not working with your linear grounding
which is the easier one that's why we
start there so we go again right and I'm
just here and he goes really hard and I
I sent it down without activating and go
really hard there you go you can see
that I end up lifting him because it's
going on the ground let's come back up
so I do the other side thanks the
blending part I want home I lock the
scapula down right everything is relaxed
I have my elbow integrity and we're just
here you could really not care about
that so everything is relaxed extension
dissention extension connection
absorption extension connection
absorption grounding
[Music]
do I know you get tired okay
we're seated so we don't have to worry
about anything else we're just working
on the test about and where he's not
actually striking me I'm just working
with the enemy but see when I reached
out my I'm gonna have this centralized
I'm not gonna go like this you get it so
you would be coming like that right you
see that so when he brings that bad hand
I'll do it done to you okay you see him
right here you're not doing this stuff
and you're doing this up and up and poom
so you go home pop got it so I would he
goes up and I would be here right he
goes around it right I had the center
line you see my intention has got to be
warm up and of the center line what I'm
seeing is this you see that or I'm
seeing this your hand is going this
extension is up on the center line so
you can chill out and you're just gonna
give me the fluidity up to TRO mom okay
again oh just do the string
okay so look it looked away your hand is
are you ever going to get to the outside
no you're never gonna get to the other
side so what's happening is you're
coming over to here do you see that so
my elbow is not going to be as if I'm
doing shomenuchi there's a slight
lateral there you go okay and calm down
because no one's hitting anyone that's
it
calm down centerline centerline so
you're afraid of getting hit but I'm not
gonna hit you I already told you that
hey that's it you're gonna slow down
good again that's it um stick to your
mission and you'll do it right you're
defending yourself right now you want to
do this do you understand
so there you go okay so down though oh
that's where I am home centerline you're
defending yourself again no
so I'm gonna do that I supposed to end
up here right so I'm gonna do do you see
how you did that you're like this a Mike
can I ever get out there I'm never gonna
get out okay so I'm here like that he
comes up the center line that's it and I
don't freak out this is the drill hmm
not this to get it hmm
I give him the center line he fills and
absorbs fills and absorbs so you're
leaning hmm that's it hmm and he's not
going backwards out of the way right
he's not going sideways he's coming up
the center like I'm not doing the drill
don't tarry back sent my home that's it
okay
[Music]
same side every time
I'm here elbow in your strike right
hands up here you know you're not maybe
that there do anything right Thank You
Angus right
I am I am absorbing you but you don't
let your your integrity go do you
understand
so that is doing I am doing that but you
don't let that happen
right what do you let happen instead
know you body booze okay oh that's it
did you keep your strike okay it's now I
have so base like a beginner mistake do
you understand what you were doing so
you felt the friction of the absorption
of that and you did your arm rather than
a century
okay so boom don't fake it I can do it
connection push right absorb oh right
can push right see remember you have
your drill and you you're testing
whether I get using my deltoids or not
go right I can lift you do you see and
absorb and that's where I have done so I
have to rotate my wrist
that's what absorbs it
[Music]
so let's slow it down
push push I want some power so I'm here
and I feel that extension connection
absorb redirection not like this look
this looks like it works it does not
work it's not like Heat oh that's the
clash but there is a way of absorbing it
you see you're on the inside doesn't
mean that you have to clash with it the
spiral will take the energy and redirect
it so you go a little quicker with more
muscle okay so I'll start over and he
goes you see I didn't even do the other
part because his elbow what happens is
he comes here like this that elbow is
gonna feel that sumia touch without me
actually doing it so he goes
you see Oh boat but all I do now is I
had my body work to give it some iegc
so we go boom you're here you're here
right home this part that you guys are
seeing is not used to push on this this
is me going around the contention point
you see we're here and I'm going to go
around the contention point but I'm not
doing that
that part happened here
[Music]
at this point right at this money hey so
when I'm here like that like okay
exactly he the harder he pushes go right
the more his balance is affected do you
understand so there's no point in
getting all tiny and Linden push back on
you just hold your position
hold your oh and I'm doing the same
thing so we started with this kind of
your outer inch we started for this
static drill and we just you all you're
very close some of you are very far
though oh this is not I cute right so
you go centerline absorber centerline
absorb boom centerline
as your osseous above it looks like this
sorry it looks like this but it's not
don't do that you're not going to be a
teenager for forever
I understand so move properly and you're
getting you're gonna be in range and
absorb you you're going here we might
even be we might even be here like this
okay right and so when he goes to throw
you can just go across right boom that's
it
bring your body like you're gonna okay
so I'm gonna come from the center line
alright you understand and now I'm gonna
come like this so the center line you
guys are all going go
what will you go like that you know what
it's comedy that's the only way that's
going to work first of all and then you
did affect his attention because you
didn't give him anything to think about
do you understand so when I'm when I'm
here like this right if once once he
starts opening up I'm I'm doing that he
more runs into that kind of thing do you
understand and I absorb it versus
the block no right here there it is can
you guys see a difference so we're back
to our static learning drill and
everyone's going like that do you see
this angle let him run oh I felt it let
him run into it
and you absorb it it's pressing on you
make it not press on you you got have
absorption here and then you lock this
what you listening for the same time
what you want to do instead is absorb be
seen oh don't disconnect please big in
space okay so your ear here and then you
move it
at this point right I'm not gonna go
[Music]
right my emphasis is wide on the yen
angle you get it so don't keep so you
can go so this this hand this hand is
this hand so hope you think same exact
idea this starts from here Oh